a campaign to win hearts and minds
senegal's ruling party coalition
candidate alpha c
wants to become the mayor of ghingenio
once a thriving railway town abandoned
by the state
gone are there generations of syrian
lebanese and malians
who settled by the railway line
exporting textiles peanuts and cotton
this no longer the gateway to africa it
is now a place where the young want to
leave to go to europe
alpha c wants to see ginginio return to
its former glory
senegal mostly coming out of the big
cities is a very poor country these
people
are in need of new infrastructure
they're in need of a new hope even
something that they can rely on there's
nothing worse than use that don't have a
hope of a better future at the
inauguration of a new intercity rail
line in dakar president makisel promises
a better future despite an economic boom
many young people feel left behind
in march nationwide protests erupted
triggered by the arrest of opposition
leader usmansanko people looted foreign
supermarkets businesses denouncing
growing inequality poverty and
unemployment
the populist politician sanko is running
for mayor in the southern town of
zigesha
there is no way that my political party
will lose these local elections
we have come here to strengthen our
political foundation
this is where we originate from at the
last presidential elections i won most
of the votes here i have come to confirm
my support and safeguarding
but for voters many of the pledges made
by past mayors remain unfulfilled in
ginginio the promised football stadium
is health built and the ice factory is
still not completed
people are still waiting for the
promised development funds coming from
dakar to arrive to this remote railway
town
but in certain areas there's still no
electricity or running water and there
hasn't been a train running by for
almost two decades there's a sense of
frustration
among people here towards the political
system
and politicians and the challenge for
candidates is to try to convince people
to come out and vote in this local
election
with over 225 thousand candidates most
of them running for the first time
this poll could become a turning point
changing senegal's political landscape
nicholas hawk al-jazeera gingenu